I've recently developed a nasty case of hitting the phobia,
generally suffer from anxiety surrounding sleep.
It's become a significant negative force in my life,
cause unknown,
I'm rather well put together and successful across many domains.
Any advice?
Yes,
go to bed later.
So one of the things that happens to people when they're having a hard time
going to sleep and their sleep is disrupted is that they tend to go to bed
earlier to catch up on their sleep.
And that actually has a counter that's cut,
that works at counter purposes to what they're trying to attempt.
What you want to do is delay your sleep until you're really quite tired.
So stay up much later.
Get up at the same time in the morning,
but move your sleep time later,
maybe half an hour night until you actually do fall asleep.
Um,
the other thing that you could look into is that there are relaxation exercises.
Behavior therapist offered those,
but I'm sure you could find one online at a breathing exercise.
And so often what you do is imagine you're laying in your bed and you're
nervous.
And so what you do is you concentrate on your feet and you flex your toes and
then breathe in and out and relax them.
And then you flex your ankles or their soles of your feet and,
and breathe in and out and relax and do that with every muscle group all the way
up your body and remember to breathe deeply and regularly and that can help
regulate your anxiety.
So I would say stay up later till you're clearly tired.
Um,
the other thing you might try is sleeping in a different room.
and then the final thing is there are pretty effective sleep medications like
Zap laplant for example,
which is seems to be pretty effective.
And if you're really having a hard time sleeping,
maybe you could try something like that and see if it and see if it helps.
You don't have to try it forever.
But,
so the simplest thing to do though is to go to bed later and because you'll be
more tired and more likely to fall asleep then.
And it's really not going to cause you any trouble,
so that's what I recommend.
Okay.